la suite de notre feuilleton et je vous
rappelle que depuis le début de la
semaine nous suivons les spécialistes de
météo france
ils scrutent le ciel bien sûr mais
traque aussi l'épaulement aujourd'hui un
avion équipé comme un laboratoire va
traverser les nuages qui entourent paris
et ce ne sont pas des cumulonimbus
c'est chimistes ont déposé leur piège
leur mission traquer les polluants dans
un avion transformé en laboratoire
hollande concentration composition
chimique propriétés physico optique des
particules rien ne doit échapper au
flair des chercheurs
l'objectif du programme c'est vraiment
d'aller étudier des polluants présents à
l'état de creysse est donc là il est en
train d'installer celle ci va permettre
de piger ce composé donc en fait il
s'agit d'une solution chimique qui va
souffler dans un certain sens inverse on
va ensuite récupérés dans des flaques
haut et qu'on allait lui fera ensuite au
laboratoire décollage de pontoise pour
un vol d'une durée de quatre heures ils
en ont dirigé vers le plessis belleville
dans monte en spirale jusqu'à 3000 m un
commando composé de scientifiques de
météo france et du cnrs
altitude de vol 600 mètres à l'est de
paris là où s'accumulent les particules
poussé par les vents dominante
quand il n'a pas les mains dans les
cartons christophe a la tête dans les
nuages
aujourd'hui à toulouse il teste un
ballon sonde en latex
maintenant il reste à lui ont fait et le
but c'est d'atteindre un équilibre c'est
à dire de venir soulever les poids
correspondant au matériel emporté le
matériel emporté son descente de mesures
atmosphériques à la banque le mans doit
être rapide mais qui valent en d'un kilo
d'instruments miniaturisés le gaz le gaz
utilisé les lieux
et
chaque année plus de dix mille balles
ensemble sont envoyés dans les airs par
météo france
sérieux comme métier ça gonfler des
ballons comme ça c'est très sérieux
parce que comme tout le comme tous les
appareils
il faut savoir bien le faire pour
atteindre des objectifs recherchés
c'est à dire sur le gonfle mal on aura
sûrement pas les altitudes prévu bon je
vais venir accrocher un des appareils de
mesure qu'on veut contrôler un bras de
capteurs qui mesurent en fait qu'ils
supportent déjà un capteur de
température et un capteur d'humidité
il faut ensuite de petits doigts de fée
pour accrocher les sondes et on n'oublie
pas la carte de visite s'il vous plaît
donc on rajoute sur les acteurs pour
indiquer aux gens qui éventuellement
autour des matériels ça donne des
consignes pour savoir ce qu'il ya des
gens qui vous dira mon genre on en
reçoit régulièrement
merci messieurs allez à l'air d'envol
vite
ça c'est sympa comme métier quand même
envoyer des ballons quand il fait beau
dit rien c'est un peu plus dur qu'est ce
que va faire le ballon revient aux
serbes
il va se dilate et jusqu'à ce que notre
enveloppe crack 1 et 2 le devrait a
éclaté vers 30e
c'est bon c'est bon ah oui il se dilate
il se dit là bien notre ballon et puis
il va maintenant nous envoyer se mesure
par ondes radio toutes les secondes
température pression
l'humidité force et direction des vents
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce qu'ils éclatent dans
la terre 40 2 les instruments viennent
de détecter un nuage de pollution
les véhicules à moteur
le chauffage urbain et l'industrie sont
les responsables de ces panache de
pollution
réel danger sanitaire ils peuvent
voyager sur plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres